thank you good afternoon everybody
welcome to this meeting of Stratford
district councils covenant I'll flip it
what is refreshed out to their summer
holidays
we'll start with apologies for absence
Thank You chairman just one apology from
the chairman of the council and the vice
chairman of the council's in this place
I think that's what mr. shape is just
dollars like right anyway welcome can I
also welcome councillor Jefferson where
is he right having been recently
appointed to the cabinet to his first
meeting and also at the end next council
Richards is a strange face to some of us
but hopefully we'll get to know him soon
he's in his first day at work here and
been subjected to a cabinet meeting mr.
sukyohama who has joined the management
team at Stratford district councillors
head of transformation or even
infrastructure right never very good on
names may write disclosures of interest
any item any item look people want to
declare no no right minutes last meeting
was on the 31st of this even July not
December where am i today but anyway the
issues are that those minutes have been
circulated publishes the notice of
decision so I don't have an issue with
them is it your wish I sign these is a
true record of that meeting
great thank you yes I noticed that
counts rankings and apologize for
evidence that there as well but then why
I Timothy Fox for notice of motion
temporary accommodation for the homeless
this is a motion that has been put
forward to Council
has twice been referred to on the front
page of the Stratford observer but mr.
counsellor riches will give us an update
on the situation and then we'll decide
how we're going to handle this motion
Thank You chair I thought was gonna be
introducing it but you've done a very
good job of that already you'll see the
the full notice of motion on the page
nine of your report and to give a little
background this is something that's very
much on the council's agenda
homelessness it came to the working
group for the strategic review earlier
this year as something that needs to be
reviewed we had a report on the 25th of
May from the housing communities manager
that was suggesting quite a large
proportion of families and people in be
MBS somewhere close to 40 I'm very
pleased to see that that number has
reduced recently to eight I'm looking at
Rob weeks just to confirm that I'm
absolutely right on that but a huge
amount of work has been done by this
council and its officers and they should
be commended for the work that they've
done and we also through from the
recommendation from that working work
stream we have to our full all housing
working group had a recommendation from
there that we set up a working group
within that working group to review the
situation and to bring forward a case
for improving the provision of homeless
properties in the district so that's
something that is going forward my
recommendation to cabinet would be to
allow that working group to continue its
work and then once the report is
finalized in complete it will then come
back here for a final decision any other
further comments councillor Morse is
there we have a windfall of a million
as well of course as money from the
possible off-site developments you've
covered the figures what I would say is
so the housing teams were very good
drawing getting these numbers down over
the year it started a very high figure
early in the year it's come down
significantly now due to the work they
put in I think they're to be
congratulated on that however it's worth
noting that when we are down on numbers
of families with children in bed and
breakfast at the moment these figures do
vary they go up and down and there are
several things making life more
difficult at the moment and I think
they're likely to last the introduction
of universal credit has created problems
as has the cutback at the county council
of support for surveys anecdotally the
changes in the boy to let regime that
the government's introduced are also
having an effect and as the some
landlords are pulling air to the private
rented sector so I don't believe
chairman that the problem of families
for children in bed and breakfast is
almighty to go away now we currently
have 23 properties on lease from orbit
for temporary accommodation and I
understand that contract is up renewal
and will be tendered shortly it seems to
me chairman that the timing is no idea
if we're looking to purchase properties
ourselves which I think could have
strong financial benefit and I think
also would have the benefit of giving us
much greater control I'm taking this
outside the control of orbit German are
aware that the ONS working party is now
looking at the possibility of hostel
accommodation and that consideration is
being given to set
a housing company Borough Council can I
suggest that in the recommendation you
choose option C to refer this matter
back to ons and perhaps ask a little bit
the business case for the purchase of
properties for temporary housing
accommodation using only the courage
cell phones or funding from developers
for other site affordable housing or
indeed funding from other sources German
German are sure we would all agree on
this table it's unacceptable but have
families with children in bed and
breakfast and I think we may have an
opportunity to tackle this gaso
Jefferson
Thank You chairman I was actually on the
working group that met at 9 o'clock this
morning to look at this issue we've
identified a whole range of options on
which more work needs doing and that
work will be able to answer is in the
not-too-distant future
Castleman Thank You chairman - to follow
on from councillor Jefferson's comments
it is indeed pleasing to see that
council moss is in support of the action
that the council is taking with regards
to future provision of accommodation
Thank You councillor Richards Thank You
Gerry yes I'm very pleased the
councillor mortars in support of this he
always he has been in wet made aware
that he does sit on the floor with
housing working group so he's been made
aware of this as we've gone on from its
very start and was in fact invited to
join the sub working group to which Tony
Jefferson canceled Jeff's I'm sorry
referred to earlier
unfortunately decided declined to join
that the offer is still open if he wants
to be part of it but the first meeting
has been held I still very much of the
mind that we we go for option B which is
to defer the motion and went to we have
a report back from that sub working with
council issues
and I thanks Jeff so I've had an amount
of experience with this in so much that
it it was previously my Cabernet
portfolio but also had first-hand
experience with a family that was prunes
bed-and-breakfast which was a fantastic
thing to be able to do they were in a
pretty dire state of affairs and while I
would really appreciate if there are no
families in bed-and-breakfast the
reality about homelessness is you don't
tend to plan for it happening it tends
to be quite a reactive thing so while
those numbers are dropping down I would
fully expect them to fluctuate over time
that's kind of how it is and you know
what I'm pretty proud of the fact that
we react quickly and and resolve the
situation and it's obvious that the
offices and the covering the portfolio
holder of working hard on this is a high
priority I know that Robert has spent an
awful lot of time dealing with the
temporary accommodation that we that
we've got other the availability of that
that we've got at the moment I don't see
there's anything any need for it to go
to OSC and have the bones picked out of
it again I think that that good work
just needs to continue with the
congratulation to the officers that are
involved so I'm supportive of option
yeah sorry yeah not see the other one
option be careful careful
Thank You speaker on behalf the chair of
the Council he has asked me to raise on
his behalf the issue that whether it
should be considered a lot in light of
item 11 on the agenda today delivery of
affordable housing and the planning
business planning process that has been
proposed for that and they should be
taken in conjunction with each other
right I don't see any further hands up
right what we have to do is to decide on
a course of action today this is all
very procedural and effectively it's
been made slightly difficult by the way
that this this whole event has been
public
sighs but I'm pleased to hear counselor
Morse concede that since the motion was
first raised there has been an
improvement in the situation as far as
the council is concerned in that we have
far fewer residents in bed and breakfast
over the years we've always tried to
minimize it but I don't think we should
just necessarily get tremendously
excited at the moment because we had a
windfall
we had a windfall from the our share of
the of the sale of garages client by
Orbitz housing that actually might make
a solution easier to find but we have to
actually be guided I don't see any knees
I agree with councillor Rich's there is
absolutely no reason at all to refer
this to OSC it needs to come back to us
as a cabinet and we need to make a firm
recommendation to Council which is
within our powers so effectively what
counts the Richards has actually
proposed is not one of the three options
but he's proposed that we allow his
working group to get on with the work
that they had already started without
being prompted by an emotion at council
we were doing this anyway so that work
and then the officers will produce a
report on that work and indeed the
affordable housing working group reports
back to cabinet in any event so we will
take a report from that group when they
have completed the work and and I know
from the other work that I've done on
the strategic review group um councillor
Moss is fully aware of that because he
sat around the table with us every time
there's a meeting of that August body
and that is we are looking seriously at
ways of reducing but
sadly circumstances are such that there
is an increase but effectively by having
more property at our disposal we can
reduce the reliance on bed-and-breakfast
so the proposal from councillor Richards
is that we refer this now to the working
party the affordable housing working
group or the subgroup of it and
effectively wait for a report back to
cabinet is that agreed thank you
right item five what an warn
Neighborhood Development Plan we have
quite a lot of paperwork on this but
this is one of the necessary evils of
the stage we are at all we have to do
this afternoon
these approve the submission version of
the neighbourhood plan so we have to
agree that the modifications to the
referendum version sorry start again we
have to agree that the referendum
version contains the necessary
modifications to the submission version
got it right that time did not Mac thank
you yes and we have to therefore approve
that the referendum version is then
published and goes to a public
referendum in Wotton Warren parish do we
have a date fix for the referendum 9th
of November this has to be approved by
full council which meets on the 16th of
October so the recommendation to council
should be that we approve the referendum
version rather than all the history that
goes with it that we've got to actually
go to public referendum any comment on
that
right is that agreed thank you
then we have to move a long way through
to page 71 okay
seventy ones the next item I'll just put
a bookmark in that page page 55 this is
the Eddington and full ready
neighborhood development plan on its way
to referendum but not just yet it has to
go through a number of stages and this
stage will have been dealt with by
everything that's gone to referendum and
that is the the version comes to us
we then give it our critique behaving
like a critical friend he then goes off
to an inspector and will then have a
referendum version come back no doubt
with modifications along the way that
any form of planning inspector always
ends up creating modifications in any
planning department document so we have
effectively a schedule of comments and
the cabinet is asked to endorse those
schedule of comments in appendix one and
then the they will be the council's
formal reply and once that's been done
and the neighborhood clan can plot its
way through the next stage which I say
is going forward for examination and
then we'll have an examiner's report and
indeed further modifications as I said a
moment ago any comment on that you're
happy with the council's comments fine
right so the recommendation is that we
agree the schedule of comments and
indeed we do everything else it says
there and agreed agreed
thank you then we can move on to page 71
progress report on housing activity in
rural areas now this is a report on work
that we do in partnership with a rural
housing enabler though it doesn't work
for us but she is we pay her salary and
indeed I'm tempted to hang straight over
to either anarta or Sarah brooke-taylor
both of whom are sat there at the bank
but whichever one of you is going to
actually give us a summary of this can
you please come forward to where there's
a microphone right so issue Sarah right
fine oh no all right please introduce
your report to us thank you very much
so yes you've got before you there the
activity that's taken place with regard
to the rural affordable housing and this
is from the previous report which was
one year ago that reported that this
meeting a year ago you've got your
summary reports there and then you've
got attached to that spreadsheet which
gives the comments with regard to each
of the communities that we're dealing
with so your main rural centers your
local service villages and then the
smaller communities what we're trying to
do over the year is to turn as many of
those communities from gray red and
amber to green communities that traffic
light report their appendix one so that
is to work successfully with those
various communities to be in a position
to investigate and where possible bring
forwards rural affordable housing
okay can you clarify for us Sara on
section three delivery of rural homes it
talks about new homes being enabled
under policies in the 1996 to 2011 local
plan and that it goes on yes that is now
been superseded by our up-to-date core
strategy and policy CS 15 and a s 10
apply now these 236 homes is that going
back to 1996 indeed those are basically
coming forward under the previous local
plan policies so com1 and cty five and
then the second list and 3.2 the homes
currently under construction
they're basically coming forward and the
current course strategy so you're
looking at CS 15 and a s 10 so the two
three six were under the old local plan
and the 52 is under the current that's
correct
okay and the active engagement how are
we going to know when those are going to
get into the homes currently under
construction lists we are very hopeful
for the majority of those to actually
come forward and move lists to become
under construction within the next
possibly two to three years as you're
aware it's a can be a long slow process
there's a lot of consultation takes
place with communities parish councils
landowners right any questions from
members of the cabinet counselor
Pemberton
Thank You leader just in terms of the
eight that are under Amber and they're
the ones that you're looking to to
progress to turn those to green I'm
assuming they're well is there an action
plan in relation to each of those and
what you
level of confidence you'd been able to
or how many of those do you have
confidence have being able to convert
from amber to green by the time of your
next update certainly I'm looking at 3.5
second comment there where we've gone
from green to now in contact with
Chariton stout and parish and having
ignored previous approaches they've now
said that they would like to conduct a
housing needs survey they'd like to look
again at affordable housing for the
parish so that's something that will
happen early next year
studly I'm in contact with them mmm
excuse me but they've had one or two
issues and there they are aware that
they need to conduct another housing
needs survey but they're now looking at
doing neighborhood development plans
they will see how it fits in with that
filming turn again working on their
neighborhood development plan they've
done a general survey and we'll get
around doing a housing needs survey so
these these are all communities that are
at some stage of work and I would hope
within the next 12 months certainly
those will turn as it says from
councillor Richard thanks Jeff so just
for clarity I'm not sure why I'm asking
these gray well no I understand what
Martin's great because it's not
necessary so that whole process can just
stand still but as far as I can tell
that's gonna almost certainly be the
case for gayden light on heath light
Horne Chesterton although I can't find
Chesterton Irian so I'm just wondering
why those are down as read when kind of
feels to me like they should be gray
with the the massive quantity housing
that's gonna go in in that area almost
certainly only housing needs gonna be
addressed through that not just
localized in that area but across a
large proportion
yeah they haven't actually stated to me
at the current time that they're not
willing to progress so I do try to
pursue communities where they haven't
finally stated usually minuted that was
in a parish council meeting that they
have no desire to take anything forward
but we do remain hopeful for them to
look at a specific community LED scheme
although I appreciate your point that
they are in an area where there's going
to be a lot of housing coming forwards
yes yeah this one to add to that
sometimes in some areas where there's
lots of housing going through the parish
still wants to pursue a local choice
scheme sometimes because I don't think
the mix is right and there's some
thousand springs tonight they've got
loads of development there but they all
that she actively looking at her right
castle kettle mr. chairman I'm slightly
amused as to whether we're talking about
the provision of housing in rural areas
in this report or whether we're talking
about the activity of the growing or
housing enabler and drug team because if
we look at well the villages in my ward
Bishop to Chintan according to John
Gordon as of this morning
Bishop's has had 43 houses affordable
houses completed since the 1st of April
2011 now if you look at page 72 Bishop's
is not listed in that list and it isn't
anywhere else
age so if it is talking about the rural
housing enables activities then that's
fine if however it is looking to inform
the district council as to the level of
affordable housing provision across the
district then the absence of 43 homes
and those more since 2011 out of the
whatever the government's are there on
that we may have a very significant
different picture if we look at mobile
housing an abler
is employed purely to bring forward
mobile housing schemes so we're talking
what some of you will have heard of is
local choice of all exceptions those are
the phrases used is nothing white in
which case I think the agenda needs to
be in the form that this is purely
looking at the worldly activities role
in housing enabler and that success
rather than provision all across the
district
yes I think point no [ __ ] right sorry
mr. Webb was trying to draw my attention
to the title of the paper but I agree
yes it could be unambiguous but you
found out you know the truth any other
comments on this paper right move to the
recommendation and we're asked to
endorse that the focus continues to be
convert Emma
amber communities in the available yes
counselor issues so that is still on my
mind the whole idea that if I was
getting parish council now what I really
want somebody continuing to engage with
me to try and talk me into doing more
local need schemes I'm just not sure
whether or not in the particular case of
gayden light or light on heath whether
or not we really do need to be
continuing to canvass them so I'm
looking at the officers that occur to
react to that so my approach is a an
annual email to the parish councils
who aren't being particularly active and
then obviously more active a community
is more often I will actually approach
them obviously we do have one or two
communities that have definitely said
thank you but no thanks and so we would
probably leave it between three to five
years between approach and then we
actually do have enough work going on
but we're not constantly in
communication with them but we will
remind them of that on an annual basis
that we are here and available to them
if they wish to take advantage of the
services offered by the rural housing
neighbor
yeah that's all they have understand so
Richard I think we're kind of on the
same page but I don't think this report
discusses affordable homes so much as
local needs and local choice schemes and
that's my concern is that and I'm happy
to go with it if colleagues are but I
just feel that perhaps places like
Dayton light on light on Heath are
somewhat bombarded with massive
large-scale development at the moment I
kind of feel like it's a little bit like
rubbing salt in the Williams by
continuing to sort of push them into
doing local needs schemes I just want to
see if absolutely ideal work for me is
that all of the games light on he
perishes in this get up get upgraded or
moved across to a grade so that they're
not pushing them to try and do more
local needs local choice games
personally but if colleagues are
happened to go into it now I think at
the moment it's a matter of report and
the recommendations are there just to
keep the whole project going in the
right direction
councillor Pemberton I think perhaps
just gives some comfort to councillor
which is what I picked up was that the
enabler
and with Renata they're prioritizing
their activity they've got more than
enough to keep them going I'm not sure
we'll be bombard in anybody in
particular I think we're you know I
think that you know and also that the
messages picked up that if there is a
feeling of communities who have got
other things on the go that you know we
we are alive to concerns of communities
that feel that they are taking more than
their fair share I not be quite happy to
to leave it at that that you know to the
good sense of the officers to to push
those films that have got subtraction
which is why I'm focused on the the
Amber's turn it to green and getting
some traction there rather than if it's
a grey it's one that it's not gonna get
that much that much attention in the
short term not to labor the point that
Gaiden like on he over the next ten
years is going to transform dramatically
compared to what it looks like today so
if we get a housing needs survey done
right at this second it's going to look
nothing like that in five years time so
I see no point at all in pushing the
parishes to have more work done and
identify local choice schemes
it will change dramatically it's a new
town so you want us to pass this
resolution but put a bracket except for
going yeah class the richest thank you I
agree with kind of emptiness view there
so this is what we're given these
practice is a choice and very clearly on
page 3 of the Appendix gayden I gave not
identified and it does quite through you
say the parish council decided not to
undertake
housing needs survey until
you supplement proposals are terrified I
can only assume that means you're not
going to be so I don't think that I
don't think that needs to be a
particular issue it's something that
will be reviewed in due course I'm
entirely comfortable the recommendation
cheran are well that we move to I would
agree right do you want to vote on it
right right so I'll put the
recommendations forward then although
there appears to be a minority of one is
that a girl item eight is affordable
housing development it's a scheme at
Arden quarter I'm proposing that this
particular item gets withdrawn from the
cabinet agenda this afternoon
because from discussions and discussions
of mr. Webb as well we have identified a
number of alternatives to which this
money could be spent and we would like a
fuller report on the wider implications
and also and I'm glad councillor goggles
nodding his head to let it have the
attention of the affordable housing
working group as well and I'm sure
councillor Richards will concur with
what I'm saying yes no one okay so I
simply have drawn item nine member
development working group member
Development Programme Council Thirlwall
Thank You chairman remember development
working group met on the 2nd of August
2017 whereby both the word program for
the forthcoming year was agreed and at
the same time further training courses
were added at the request of offices at
the same time we also reviewed at the
proposed SIL training which will be
rescheduled hopefully for late October
2007
team with a specification that to course
of a particular training program will be
run one during the day and one in the
evening I asked of the cabinet to note
the program thank you
yes on until the community
infrastructure levy that is the
trainings been deferred a couple of
times because we have been waiting a
painful amount of time for the planning
Inspectorate to give us their final
report on the examination in public
which took place in two tranches the
second of which seemed an enormous ly
long time ago but anyway the issue with
that is I spoke to mr. Kerr for today
and he tells me that the inspectors
final report is now in we penciled in a
report to de cabinet on this because
although the adoption of SIL will have
to be approved by the full council we
have two opportunities to do that
between now and Christmas one is on the
16th of October and the second one is at
the meeting in December the data I don't
quite recall but it's there are those
two meetings we'd like to think we might
get it adoptable by the 16th of October
with the December date as a fallback
date what is more important than the
adoption of SIL is how we implement it
and that will require I think quite a
lot of discussion and member engagement
I certainly wouldn't want to bring a
paper for wouldn't it be my job to do so
without feeling that members of the
council that had made their observations
and had their say in a number of aspects
of the implementation of SIL so that
might effectively be more difficult to
do in fact it's probably impossible to
deal with by the 16th of
so the book but we'll see how it goes
all I'm saying is that we are in touch
now with the end of the process and it's
only been announced to me this morning
that we've got to that stage and
therefore we will work with it
objectively and as quickly as possible
but if you want to blame anybody can you
blame the plan Inspectorate please not
this councils fault the whole matter has
been delayed clearly training will have
to fit in with whatever we see about the
work program okay and that will be
further discussed between myself and mr.
Webb right so we've only got a summary
so the answer is we note
we can either note the program or refer
it back their proposal is to know that
the program is a degree white all right
some been remember development working
group planning training hours Thank You
chairman following a request from the
head of planning and housing and
consultation with both chairs of
planning committees the working group
debated proposal designed to encourage
better attendance at site visits the
member development working group
supported this proposal and asked that
the cabinet approved a recommendation on
page 87 of your agenda that the planning
training definition be amended to
include one maximum training allowance
for attendance at the scheduled site
visit or multiple site visits as
arranged intended by officers be
endorsed would effect from the 1st of
October 2017 and then secondly that if
agreed then the proposal reviewed by the
member develop working group in October
2018 thank you right look at that Ward
members who are either initiating board
members generally initiate the need for
site visit
so in attending they need to be
incorporated within the training arms
benefit and therefore suggests that
there is a slight change wording to
include attending of ward members mr.
John what's the process for engaging
with Ward members I was invited to a
site visit recently but I wouldn't have
said that was the norm you're looking
terribly worried mr. weeks I was hoping
you could tell us what the
caocao thermowell Sharon the current
situation is a warden member can request
into certain conditions at the site
which it does actually take place that
is the normal process if any other body
who is entitled to ask for a site visit
then which is not the warden member the
ward members is normally advice so there
is that situation there already
however going back to a counselor
kettled point to made on behalf of the
German when we actually discussed this
we did actually include or in our
reasoning included the ward member
themselves of that particular learning
application if they were actually
attending well that satisfy the chairman
of the council I'm sure it well it's
just the wording currently as proposed
it just says the planning committee
members and their father would need to
be a very slight amendment a three-year
chairman unhappy to add the addition of
the ward member it just says attendance
not by planning committee members
yes but the recommendation does not
restrict it so I think we've covered
your point with the recommendation as it
stands so that means if whoever's there
it says attendance of the scheduled site
visit bla bla be endorsed and that
therefore if the war member is there
will include that surely right is that
agreed item 10 the recommendation okay
item 11 delivery of affordable housing
options counselor Rich's Thank You chair
so this is it this is a recommendation
or paper brought by the former housing
working groups which I alluded earlier
the full house and working group is a
cabinet working group set up earlier
this year and superseded and ons task
and finish group that was established in
July 15 a great deal of work has been
done by that group over that time
looking into ways of improving the
affordable housing provision for the
district but at the same time meeting a
second objective which is to generate a
further income for for the council and
you'll see in your report we've looked
at various options of delivery of former
housing at one point one point for what
we're seeking for your approval today is
that is an endorsement that a full
business plan be produced that will
continue to look into and detail the
various options that are available and
the resources are put to that of 30,000
pounds in order to bring that business
plan forward thank you yeah so Jefferson
followed behind this proposal Chairman I
think it's potentially an excellent
initiative and we should progress it as
fast as possible
gasps the kettle thank you Miss Erin on
behalf of oh yeah I'm a certain little
separately incorporated company that's
how I read it it's the right answer
bearing in mind the operating except for
the man sat out in 1.12 etc my prayers
with joint-ventures inputs with my
thinking it is the appropriate
relationship because something of that
nature of an established Housing
Association is preferable in meeting
overall finance and management demands
having looked at their recommendation
metal processes he wonders whether
they're in the cost of local government
and therefore by having a JB might
actually we are are see effectively this
paper is here so that funding which
doesn't is not in the budget but is
certainly in the council's bank accounts
can be deployed for this purpose so
perhaps the detail of it council riches
can take away and discuss when the
appropriate issues are debated at the
affordable housing advised by the people
to whom the funding will be directed I'm
happy to to pay that and have a separate
discussion with yourself under the gem
in the council what I would say is one
of the beauties of the wholly owned
company is its ability to other forms of
well is who is going to be putting the
business plan together and do they have
the professional experience of having
done that before to ensure that the
business case business plan is
sufficiently robust to ensure quite
simply put why would I enter into a room
with someone who hasn't got experience
doing this and of course we're going to
get there be be dealing with someone who
has experience of putting this together
we've actually already met with four or
five groups who have the experience and
that's where we've got a lot of the
information from so we'll continue along
that line it's just been drawn to my
attention councillor kettle and if you
move on a couple of items and read the
minutes of the working group you will
see that some of these points have
effectively been discussed anyway right
now I hadn't spotted that mr. eagle-eyed
grafton of his responsible for spotting
that well as you know
it's one of the things he's here for to
look at detail right so I'm taking it
with no more hands out did I see your
hand go down no it's just going to kick
correct it's pet Castle Richards worst
and rather than myself right well let's
not sort of have arguments about
people's names of the similar right
recommendation that we need we support
the V for a business plan I don't think
anybody disagrees with that and that we
identify a budget of 30,000 and that
money will be drawn from general
reserves which I agree fine the
remaining items on the agenda are on
block items I haven't had any requests
to pull them out so I'm going to ask you
to note those on block as I've agreed
except for the cabinet work program
what's happened to that so the cabinet
work program was published on Friday I
do recall that so but we haven't asked
to discuss it so I'm not going to bring
it out now
thank you very confidential we can
safely agree it because we've seen it
and I move on to the last item urgent
business mr. Webb has no extra business
children thank you
with that note I'd then declare the
meeting closed thank you for your
attendance